read out the emergency declaration
announcement in the event of a fire or
other emergency please exit the building
in an orderly manner to the assembly
point which is located in the market
carpark fire action in this one is
indicated by green fire exit sign please
do not delay the evacuation by
correcting any gun awnings
we have used to lift the premises must
not be entered until the Fire Brigades
can walk here please note that is
against the law to smoke on these
premises please note that this meeting
will be audio recorded and may I also
add then please make sure your mobile
Phaedrus report me Lord I will not go we
will start with item - politics persons
having the obvious disease lady bingo
and countenances and sight politically
in don't water are there any other
apologies hurry there counselor
I really prefer any substitute menu so I
have counseled disease in rare form as
his finger yes good and counselor distr
yes so I canceled my basis yes yes yeah
I'm substituting the counsel because
I'll thank you very much any non members
attending the minutes of the meeting
held on the 27th September 2016
are they all agreed agreed
thank you variations of interest
it appears the member of bondage cancel
the other sing Deborah ray tell Council
to provide containers
I'll make a microcosm ash
right eat em in row but everybody is
going to item may item again driver this
evening member learning and development
and ask kept dancing
Leona's giving Thank You chairman
disturb a brief introduction report
pages serves six point one and the top
of six point two that's discussion on
training hell with openness municipal
year including the tendons Atlanta
sessions and opportunities provided
other than standard courses page six
point to increase some Hotel on feedback
received from members on recent courses
and any development requests for the
next year proposals that for training
during the 2017-18 program start on page
six point three the country within that
in class includes a paragraph for
thirteen responses receive in relation
to questions on when training the best
time with also a suggestion that an
e-learning module in relation to
safeguarding be rolled out to members
and a separate suggestion that the
committee may wish to emphasize the
highly recommended nature of some
training to group leaders the current
position copy the guards of parish and
town council training
connected at the bottom page 6.5
covering what's been offered over the
municipal year on the basis of
previously agreed arrangements on that
places and charging paragraph five four
days on page six point six covers
feedback online training received on a
counselor stepped out during his visits
aesthetically that we can and parish
counseling chairman the recommendations
on page six point seven pick out the
decision areas that need to be covered
by the committee and be able to you in
the committee to go through the chair
thank you but it could as ways to go to
the Foundation's one by one and then
take some questions on each one as they
arise
so the first proposal is the committee
results to receive the summary of
members attendance at training sessions
during the municipal year 2016-17 as
appended of any point in blue yesterday
on that item
whereas there is one thing to place and
I believe we're counting a attendance at
a budget away day as training is that is
that correct it's not included in the
stat oh it's not including that so it's
not raining no
so can we take that resolution to see
the summary as result it's very great in
seconds proposal is to endorse a
proposal for the content of these and
the Learning and Development Program the
2017-18
as a thousand pairs are fun for one
fourth well thank you I just want to
clarify something is not particularly
under these points let them have
attained to it alright and two points
very in here it's a straight line within
three sessions of mandatory failings of
play and sixteen seventeen and requiring
that members was not missed two
consecutive training session applies
also to members who wish to substitute
of development community now a point of
clarity I fear that this is a mistake I
don't actually disagree with it but I
think we ought to be very careful here
that the what the committee has
recommended in the past is not
misrepresented originally if you
remember we had two training sessions
for development committing mandatory
training after that it was altered to
for mandatory transactions of which
members could not miss one two
consecutive the last time it was because
of the various difficulties with the
quality of the training and the
frequency the pressure and offices
various raises it was reduced to three
training sessions a municipal year with
what was actually stated and related was
that the members must not had to attend
two out of three sessions now there is a
difference here because unfortunately
I'm not going lying the paper vote
normal one person actually stated at
that time
a thumper I don't need to do the third
one so item 2.3 we need to really bring
it because I personally think it's
correct it should be must not miss one
two consecutive but somehow that has got
lost by errors being put in the report
probably composting and I think what we
also is formally endorse that error mr.
cherry so we could do that and as soon
as the recital and and whichever item
you prefer I think would look like I
think we can do it on a motorized it
okay I suppose then that that I can take
point three at though reporting in error
should be adopted and recommended
thought Council because otherwise we're
going against what philosophers are
grade generally on a point of order you
it's as such is a listing member in a
position to be able to pose for the
committee to make a decision
I can't so I'm happy to take on that
House of Councillors person - thank you
hello secondary to chairman of the
committee could resolves that here just
as we can see at the admit it's a little
early to need to be a recommendation to
to counsel okay so le weekly about the
recommendation for
suppose Aires castle is closing the
books can do a front-flip the error in
the reported two-point trade formally
adopted however you like to word it
think we're endorsing well I'm not as
I'm the man to propose it Alexa useful
to M endorsing paragraph two point three
as as elementary planning training is
this approach it was just done will it
be wrong habit an exterior on a friend I
will elevate to executives yeah I
thought it'd always be it was before
ENSO a giant result so Jim yeah we'd be
really here substitute members how if
you're obviously not substituted for the
same person on two consecutive matings
so how does that work for the
subsequently because that member for one
who substitutes when you've got a I like
successful I think that I think I think
German is just being sure that if
someone does substitute that they're
ready to substitute they've got the same
sufficient experience and training and
the committee's I to be able to do so so
you've got a group of appointees I
understand what your site but it's not
always the substitute that's going to
come in to substitute more than once if
he does something with they don't
substitute any time so I don't see how
that rule includes and type fights given
substitute that in terms of members
substituting for another member on the
Development Committee they can only be a
substitute if they've fulfilled this
training requirement
okay
sable now I'll just how absurdly obvious
and start to say to my head Great Lakes
is free courses in a year if you think
you go to the first to be mister third
ones that still count as two consecutive
causes or you've I do every single
course that comes along to keep my
perspective it when you can't miss two
protective policies you could miss one
this gives me wine it in consecutive
amount so if you do too for if you think
your words of a lot if the last one in
the come here your days are needed first
winding the mainstream view is the loss
in the current year
you can also miss the first one corrode
the next municipal year you better knock
you out because you missed one consuming
that you pursue presented last
indefinitely it's not to consent see
once per year that's what I'm saying
it's not to take you must be here so if
you do the first two you miss the third
one we do the non first one in the next
year
you knew you out khaki makes you miss
the one before this one okay problem
okay please please read it again he
really takes care once we go to make
sure
is anybody feels that all right bye-bye
thank you we can't miss to consecutively
when run of a bridge municipal year so
if we've got my July and September
you can't miss million July you can't
live alone in September we publish
September in the next 20 months
consecutively sequential through okay
but you can obtain and then you're
eligible to I felt a gain or substitute
or one submits Sharon if I made so to
submit yourself the tribunal yes it has
been which is an option if you've not
you've not complied our members they'll
walk said should have unit
I've got a problem with this still got
problem with the substitute because
substitute has to do that so in other
words what we're saying is than 29
counselors oh sorry 13 I guess is bill
has to come to consecutive ones should
they at any time feel that they may be a
substitute for a cancer that's already
on the committee yes Wow okay I mean if
you have something you want to do
indefinitely you count yourself such
that I been up there I really like that
so please same prepare two consecutive
them even Masson missed two consecutive
not food two consecutive survival pay
you mother and miss be one of the main
secret in one now you've got to do to
this is what's confusing
current initiatives that you've got to
do to protect it but now that you must
not receive consecutive mandatory try
planning claim the group one so you must
you must not miss please consecutive
training tests or going to box and seal
in a boat before
I think we all in them all are we all
agreed on this I think we're going to
have to be very clear when this
information goes out to members
obviously we've struggled with it or
move around placement with it I think
members will struggle with it so it
needs to be extremely clear when it goes
up mr. chairman with respect it's
actually what's written here and it's
what we've been doing for a few years of
with once we went away from turn so I
don't think the members or any members
might have difficulty with the concept
but it's the existing members I can't
see any difference difficulty and surely
they can approach member great points of
clarification most beautiful
you've got to cancel the Masons here
tonight chairman enough Stiles I do
apologize kind of sure that we are
addressed thank you
and I'm going to ask you to ensure that
the mimic actually encompasses the
scenarios that we've talked about this
evening because actually putting in the
news the scenarios I mean if you pick up
the paper you understand it if you pick
up a minute to understand it so there's
no misunderstanding by members so I
agree with counselor Specter I think it
needs to be made very clear and if the
scenarios can two or three scenarios can
be put in the minutes and that would be
absolutely perfect I agree any [ __ ]
compass and I'm sure it will be I think
for my men
excuse me I think it's more around the
substitute system I think members are
still unclear exactly how much of work
well I think I think if we put it
briefly the rule applies as substitutes
needs elected in the same way and to the
exact same extent as to substantive and
isn't the Development Committee I
understand that but I think members it
ought to be laid out clearly from if so
there's no question library 430 market
they don't it's at least the third
scenario so children you can see if it
helps chairman when we've got the
Charter for elected members of elements
of Council we're the only ones that have
managed to solve and introduce some
Comanche training and if you've seen a
great interest because it is an easy
thing to do and this council managed to
you know create something so it's you
know in context
other councils almost look at us how did
you manage that on them I can see the
manager
are getting all in favor of all that
potential for does anybody want to baby
I'm happy happy okay that's a great the
third item is considerable time in
signings to remain at 1:30 p.m. and then
setting p.m. from the Georgia courses or
what whether they should be offered
active time today and if I may I think
occurred first times I think the setup
is those that are aligned to that got
activity but those that are working able
to be needing such a result I can attend
in essence you know you're referring to
the existing for existing m113 cents
versus Casimir's investor I mean I'm
happy doing in my time super fine it's
been two seven two thousand seven thirty
sometimes and sometimes 730 client later
in the evening especially especially
when you come to the winter time and you
have leave leave an angel channel
Cortana gets quite some she's a really
central problems and thirty person
cattle I think well I said that I I
think although being ones which are
being offered here I've worked in the
past January I think that they're still
needs really for a morning session
you're young you should be taken care of
the discipleship web which happens
nowadays for people may be working more
so maybe work in afternoons to evenings
or some people might be working evenings
I think
the option needs to be there too so we
don't discourage other people from
becoming counselors and also all the I
don't like about at 7:30 start is it
doesn't allow people who work in London
to get here I know there's a number of
people trying to do travel to get 7:30
community starts because of their their
jobs the iStent about moving into seven
o'clock lament places I think morning
ones can be important for other members
who have different different types of
working patterns that myself or other
people say oh so what are you suggesting
a morning session as well as the art
alone again and anything leaving yeah
particularly if it's a compulsory will
make you free shipping
I think cancel each nation I think
that's most it thank you mister thanks
mister chairman tom we must members what
they failed and when we have the
information in front of it it was safe
to say quietly disregarding that and
statistically if you look at the
information there is pro bravely which I
admit that I've not many responses that
we can assume that people haven't
responded and they haven't got strong
preference so taking that you've got
full for the afternoon you've got the
total of possibly five people for the
morning you put six papers was a great
preference expressed here for the
morning and for the afternoon
I can't switch over the four afternoon
evening so in the evening is actually a
lesser preference I'm not sure that we
can run three sessions but I think there
should be consideration given to
occasionally doing a morning apparently
doing enough to do there should be some
variation currently I would find corners
better have financing very very
difficult
I'll find a less difficult path but
other people will have other
requirements I mean some houses
she put some counters were very long
house and we need to have a variation of
training that encompasses the majority
of painful that there's always criticism
that people don't attend these sessions
there's various reasons why people don't
possibly because the content isn't
applicable but also to the timing we
haven't had to my knowledge a morning
session and I think we should introduce
one or two even if it's just one of the
mandatory planning one of the other
sessions so that we can see if the
attendance is better when different time
factor because really the point of
actually putting these course along if
we want people to obtain we want them to
attain with the least difficulty for
their personal circumstances like your
preferences why you confirm of a is how
many people do we need to on a training
call to maybe just effective and
successful if you've got too many
training courses more enough and having
other bouncers I mean are people a lot
of my only concerns on that dr. P
understand what counting summations them
typically [ __ ] sort of have a comment
on a scenario if firm if there is only a
morning and an afternoon train session
is a mandatory training and the
counselor cannot leave work how is that
dealt with
imagine probably a term for the times uh
I have to admit that I'm a [ __ ]
mauryans and once you don't get home
till Prats six gone just one six a lot
the same time and we mutate before come
so early trading or any any committee at
all so you know you just are unwind and
then Portland then take you to what what
what ever you going to do so 7:30 so I
do for take a lot self and go out I mean
you know I'm at eight o'clock night and
I'm sure there's making many they get
out of all seven and then get hunting
like for the legs out there's a blockage
on what practicality is a quote um I
just got the sense that suggestion is
perhaps a test of some warnings and
perhaps but it's for members that
doesn't preclude perhaps a morning and
an evening image is all know it I think
there was a general sense of three a day
varies a bit bitumen that you know maybe
testimony the only the only observation
practically and and there's no doubt
ways ways of ways around it if you've
got an external triangle and they're
coming from a distance they may have to
stay over there if they've got a morning
depending on how far they've come
but then again some sessions are
delivered by by officers and in any
event I think it's been suggested as a
possible test but it is that that's
that's enough for the committee's it for
400
giving could I gather hours to my Snider
place with if it is a morning afternoon
it's magic renounce there can be guilty
assembly Carly but if I could not
release it on you I think it's going to
be the same answer if it's an afternoon
evening a summer consequent remember
that that happens so he's a same
scenario but I think mr. Vostok actually
somebody out quite well suggestion isn't
that we do free the suggestion isn't
that we switched the morning and
afternoon the suggestion at the moment
because of the results of the survey
which presumably remembers have built
created included is that some morning
sessions are given as alternative to the
afternoon sessions and then taken
forward for that and they could be done
with in-house training which would incur
any extra comes are you referring this
to the daytime session so definitely
still attending yes I think it was
really more in an afternoon in some
cases yes and I got a sense chairman of
his members work my need today was a
sort of test suggestion that you know it
could be the results could be looked at
if that was a route to go you know it
comes back to the committee did were any
more attendees did it you know that was
sleep because we've a testing an FBI
Salinas Iraq oh I noticed one we think
training sessions are on there's usually
an email goes out and good that's asked
us if we can attend
have we got any information on who
actually heading bother to reply sunny
lieutenant turned up or have any
information on who actually applied
setting attained and actually did turn
up that may help with
timings there's what's happening to last
year
we have got a report of people here so
making that might help because a little
bit in the air at the moment we don't
know who's going to turn up to what
station exit people even going to turn
up or leave the reason whether it is a
reason why I didn't see it in the
dumpster
I think it's fair to say that whatever
we do is stop us together that you have
many ways we had to live yeah I'm still
unclear as to value this are we talking
about with tiling the evening session if
I met occasionally swapping the mornings
and afternoons around press earlier I
understand personally don't have a
problem with this Patterson I've been a
well Pointon saying that possibly having
the morning lock lips I don't I think
now I don't you as long as I scream I
don't think the general feeling is that
that's like is being here by myself a
little except of quarterman if there is
external that tutored folks don't we're
coming in to do the playing I think that
that's that's where we could really only
have afternoon or evening or even
sometimes only only afternoon there are
some occasions and I think to accept to
expect an external player to do the
morning then hang around the rest of the
day to do the evening sessions yes we
have something highly cost earned
relationship can sustain if we have had
some like evening ones as I remember
we're not actually aware the doors or
Lincoln it was owned like I was
attending was like a couple times as I
remember so near the ending I know the
evening one start at 7:30 and I know you
probably like to start earlier so awful
six seven twelve it's just below my neck
again I think that our argument on both
sides on that so yeah but it's will be
fun this Thanksgiving I'm I'm quite
happy to we
the situation what we particularly
inaudible mandatory ones the military
training-wise the mandatory appeals the
monetary licensing that maybe we can
substitute morning and afternoon not in
every case but in some cases maybe one
of each to see how it works I don't know
I don't think you can have two
consecutive no no one is suggesting it
you're doing planning looking at
planning yes really
so one of those could be a morning
evening one of those could be an
afternoon evening and the other one can
be afternoon and evening
so you've achieved your scenario and if
you were doing licensing you could do
the same if you're doing appeals you
could send a completely licensing is
only an afternoon session so there
they're mandatory video event there is
no evening session emotions well there's
there's an issue so the ways because if
it is just a set day so somebody's
working and the employer refuses to let
and god oh really can they can refuse
then they wouldn't be able to attend
that mandatory training for licensing or
appeals so here I think in reality those
that on the license committee committee
meetings I'd rue the day
and if members are required to sit off
at an absolutely today to Sochi unlikely
that somebody with working during the
day to work the other night
I think you're prejudging I don't think
that's clear judging and I would also
put to you that we do have license
committee meetings during during the day
and maybe in reference to those members
who are all working that maybe maybe we
could do a licensing Commission meeting
in the evening as you know there's not
that it's not what we're here for
but I'm suggesting that if the response
we've had four members is going to be
applied fairly then we should be
considering the morning and afternoon
that something we should be doing at the
very least for all the Clair training at
least in specie
at least in opportunity as otherwise
it's not being otherwise you're
directing it simply a plan which I don't
think is right or intentional okay
that's where I stand
okay so whatever proposal comes forward
that's where I stand with regards to
training finishing later than the
half-past nine that is a some concern to
me I have been on this council at 17
years which so most people will say it's
part of but I've never had a training
session finish go on quarter to 10:00
and that's not very enthusiastic members
with enthusiastic trainers I've never
I've never known a pure training session
finish after that time so I really like
to know which ones are finishing it up
off ten because I think that's another
issue and I'm really worried about that
because that's far too late for people
to be sitting through training and and
being asked was simply assimilate stuff
that's manager probably you could ask I
mean I've read on the unloving
for 13 years knives Ivanova and meeting
go on must kill help us my poor sister
I've been created something that make
triangles has gone to the top okay it's
a relative element oh it's a marriage to
be still to me late it's too late
Thank You Sherman for arrogance carrying
on with it I make six we have power
proper of a fundamental problem
like I understand the issue in licensing
is attorney in particularly afternoon
the reason why some members cannot go on
licensing because they can't attend the
training field and we are there were
exploding members from participating
fully in the council and the phone will
be appealed now with the situation I
don't know everyone knows us because we
have a mixture of self-employed retired
etc but generally speaking if you are an
elected councillor you can request
tunnel through your employer usually
it's unpaid some employees pay but the
employer has the right to not grant that
which should it affect the business so
you have a right to ask but you don't
want to be granted therefore we have we
have members around type of the world
varies I mean our people with most value
to third shifts various different
lifestyles and training and our
committee but I've been just on the
afternoon is excluding a large
proportion of councillors I think we
ought to be looking so the training
staff include all cancers so we should
be asking for separate second sessions
for licensing and appeals I think is
another one into the same time otherwise
anyone that works mind survival lament
is excluded but then
so for that's surely not the intention
we're training and I appreciate is
difficult the yellows responses here
shows difficulty the ability of going to
field training is there only six members
on the appeals committee and it's
delivered by Rochford officers and is
only requirement to attend every other
year that ok not so much finishing
that's not too much of an issue but when
I was working I couldn't go on licensing
because why wouldn't I was the clearly
from doing that so it was an option and
fact that are fortunately not from a
very long period of time but the other
members not have the same distributions
and I think it's something we need to
take into account
thanks mr. Johnson was a comment on that
people we welcome press apologies German
I'm I'm swallowing myself where the
licensing hearings are in a way this
this isn't listed as a disconnected
where the licensing here is ten point O
in the daytime because of the players
involved in terms of partners all of us
of human processing hearings so there is
that factor however is for the committee
immediately if you give asking for two
lots of time off your employer if you
wanted to go to a moving across the
training so to that extent you know
really that the committee might might
feel to introduce to all or have it back
at the next meeting with a bit more
analysis um but it's
it could choose to Cervantes switch ends
of lettuce definitely take to it several
quotes first of all the point on
training in his writing other way one of
the things that very often happens we
train planners once the course is
finished members don't tend to keep the
trainer talking refer those points after
the official claim was finished so
that's always coming from the players
point of view but with regards to being
member of the nicest committee which and
I have been myself and to make the
hearings when you have a license hearing
has to be done for today because of the
legal representation and those various
things so if somebody is going to be a
member of life's committee they've got
to be prepared to come for some time the
other concern that I have and I think
John touched on it was the training
certainly when I was on the last
committee the training was given by
external trainers abdominally sisters
those days and the point of view there
and of course there will be a cost to
that and there would be a higher cost if
you expecting a barrister for example to
come out during the course of the
evening and you probably know better
than I the sort of cost of legal people
coming out to those sorts of things and
so I would be concerned about it and I
think we've got to keep an eye on that
situation as well that would be a high
cost catalyst risk
I know that when we are asked to sit on
only other committees especially on the
licensing we are told that the train is
in the afternoon and that the any here
in to do it licenses will be in the
elephant innocent people who and now
obviously if they feel they and they
can't do it and they were pronounced for
so we are there are people there were no
fools they better change the options and
attendee so they probably are people in
their own areas that people don't to do
anyway yes there was actually one
training one licensing here which went
on two days it's the first time units
come under the stand is waiting of
people being restricted to being on
certain communities and training
obviously they isn't very good unless
there's a very good reason why so maybe
looking made real public why these
meetings happen during the day every
council would be aware that especially
the live ones and England someone like
myself as member and it explains it
physics never come up before that
certain meetings can only be truly done
after the training I don't think you can
mess about with it so quickly but yes
there are many people no other two
different ships and they will be
experiencing reservations so that starts
slowly and just do the ones that are not
compulsory tracking and start messing
about with that because we gas a little
bit of a mess
let's try one which isn't compulsory and
is given by an officer so we run no
extra expense and see how that goes and
then see that the people are happy now
we'll be happy with that little idea and
hopefully with a better response from
the questionnaire than what we've got
now but it is a very well can't be
bothered sort of response maybe they
can't be bothered because they don't
think it's going to change but now is
the time to start changing it because
people's helmets have changed but the
ones who were called I you can't remove
their opportunity to be trained during
them so let's leave like playing one in
the evening and will allow the daytime
ones that will give the people a chance
to circuit gender so just a thought for
the committee there are the rather there
is trading of delivered by officers some
of it's highly recommended and in that
sense the committee might think that
there that that's the ones be allowed to
see additional attendance so you used
just as a thought if you were going for
introducing a morning for long mandatory
you can select one or two highly
recommended and maybe see every year how
that's if that's had any impact but
that's just good I think another thing
also what month major difficulties is
whatever we do it's not going to it's
not going to completely under play
anyway
so our calendars doing something close
look just moments before you I thought
your by having the gradual credit
customers might really in fact feel
better well now I officers a little shed
you are if you're happy to pass to
misplace bunnelby come after us from
other states going to add but when I
joined and was a place to the licensing
committee I think it was the only
committee I could actually go on and
there was any option really interesting
I was told yes the the hearings were
during the day but I was also told that
my training would take place over three
long very long evenings with castle
point Borough Council and strangely so
my training was in the evening and it
was with another council and we did that
to actually lower the cost of see that
the training so the issues of Paris is
attending in the evening simply didn't
wasn't encountered and more particularly
that we shared the training and I just
wonder you know particularly its
Licensing's beliefs three sessions but
that maybe we can start to share with
other councils
but thank you is the perspective license
in the game having beetle license you
know for a few years here and there
I'm it is rather a large committee and
I'll take it's a lot of committee so
that when Sonia finds round signal is
fine for the three people and a
substitute she needs out that many
people I think the point I want to make
eased license give me just ignore about
just serving on those subcommittees
license and also approves our policies
under the Vice the licensing for
gangjae's compliment all form of
different ones so you're not just there
to serve on a subcommittee for a hearing
you're there to to discuss the approve
and decide on policy nothing that's
where it becomes bit more important and
you start wondering why should they have
to meet in the oscidyne a historically
they had but it's about the other
committee which we really doesn't meet
in the afternoon for some reason I don't
know why and which guys countries why
just about you folks but you can't have
every right on your marketing si self
there they just it still does get to the
majority of being on site couldn't
amazing and the training would be not
just all the hearings with the trade
would also healthy policy that was just
comment on smoking chairman I think it's
been quite a while since committee like
the licensure committees met that
consider policy but but yes it also
combines policy under on if I'm not it
was that with that it's a policy to a
tower that will do that for you
happen yeah student eventually now in
wine was it because I've never talked in
my life I was going to enjoy comfortable
I was going to say I can't see any
reason why the community
from the technology because I felt
amazing if I really next year I did one
time it was on the last year of thing
what I wanna do is one where we we
inserted key customers he reasserted
thinking about my time equally I mean
certainly you know I would attention
obviously should be looking at them to
have them as evil meeting guide like
other committees where it's where it's
policy in the same way as the licensure
committee might have signs meet so the
People's Committee Mike sometimes policy
yeah this is moderation in the morning
as well yes yes as far as the Boeing
that amazed and remember to infinity n
mmm so we will look to that Germany dear
I'm beginning to wonder whether it's
desirable that the officers actually
consider all these various options and
come back for a further report before
any final decision is made so that
members can actually look at the
ultimately ups and downs of each option
and get some domination
Gemini I wouldn't be happy with this
being deferred for over a few months I
rather high rather say I'd rather there
was a proposal which was clear clear and
determined and the committee votes are
and it is but if that's not possible
then at least there should be a you know
a proposal that allows the office is to
look at the opportunities to introduce
different fitment timings for certain
committees I don't see a lot of fun with
the officers and you agreeing to an
appropriate use of different times that
closes I agree that would be difficult
because I would I would not know how
many members would have difficulty how
they would approve so I think my
difficulty at the moment is that yes I
am looking for a proposal but
understanding it as a members comment
there are several beginnings of totals
but I haven't actually had a proposal
come forward edge yet they know it's
everywhere
perhaps if I can help help you and I
suggest that we propose that we maintain
the evening set and look at the various
committees as to whether it will be
possible or practical to offer a morning
session subject to the trailer being
available because the trainer might be
variable and presumably being an officer
if it's not so than it's also easier but
I would suggest that that's probably we
need to be met a little bit flexible
with that particular situation I don't
think we can actually say and that
training for a particular committee must
be in the morning and the evening I
think it's kind of
paint on water training years and I'm
just going to be given the training as
to how that can actually work so but
with the possibility of giving some
morning sessions but I'm working on the
basis determine the opposite select via
the officers get six
I'm having to make that proposition so
I'd say the proposal is that the repeat
an evening session in any event where it
already exists and there be morning or
afternoon sessions in addition at the
officers discretion eyes upon Jim and if
we agree the morning sessions and I've
no objection to morning sessions I think
we should agree a time in length so that
this is clear what time there will be in
in the Nordics acts like an amendment
proposal that the morning session is at
10:30 to 12:30 essentially mother's work
is speak with some of these training
sessions and turn off as long as
required so you couldn't do that was
that we did it and M&M you don't know if
you have to do it from 9:30 till one
o'clock yes we have no choice take 10 to
10 to 12 as you know when I heard you so
yeah you got to account for it to an
hour of our session again till we make
it 9:30 this morning because yesterday
exactly the boy Jeff the mandatory
training wall because during the day
sometimes day and evening should be
offered must be also because I can't
attend most evening sessions will -
attending sessions I thought that was a
lot of people I'm going to say no
mandatory once they've got to be offered
absolutely
especially sometimes I'll go fit so they
can't both work out if the if your
proposal refers aliens and non-mandatory
I think so disguised as you described
first I'm probably start getting in
students not only highly dependent
members suggestion that we took to get
out the magical so the effect is that
right I'm going to take the vote on this
now have the proposal people EPP
mutation see we introduced morning or
afternoon sessions of the officers
discretion the morning's session
starting at night person and Italy for
non mandatory training skills I want to
speak a gangster well the reason I want
to speak against is because there's been
a quite a number of people from the very
beginning of this discussion this
debating we were talking about the
issues they had with mandatory sessions
because you know to be fair and if
you're unable to make a particular
training session that is highly
recommended then but that's very
unfortunate but it is very good because
the officers do send out all the
material and I certainly need to use
that opportunity to to need to come back
up to date if that's if that's helpful
but it is the mandatory sessions where
members can lose their opportunity and I
don't agree with leaving the mentoring
sessions out of this arrogant I shall
vote against on those for those reasons
does anybody hopefully pretty physically
chairman have we any indication on this
is well out Luna have anything any
indication what any courses you can
think of at this moment in time that
makes mayor evil wind
sessions which all
planet mandatory funding they'll also be
beneath in Israel own tender skin so
that's for me that to me that's not a
problem is such I'm not sure I thought
it was originally a group that the man
that you're running would be 1 and 3
would be mourning it and then we say to
lost it that's too sure if I could come
back from what I was proposing if taking
a man to try planting triangle which
means me the sticky one
and yes we would maintain the evening
for training but depending who the train
is it was asked in the daytime session
as to whether it's going to be practical
to do it in the morning or to have to do
it me often but some trainers may not
want to stand around your back so I
think in these that needs to be flexible
for the officers to be able to work to
use them but if we collapse I claim
telling you we can't expect for reals
when it opposes but it be will it be the
morning or the afternoon if he had got
insulation quiet that way they all they
take these things into account but you
want your you're saying is you wanted to
apply to mandatories so I just wanted to
point you to paragraph 4.10 page six
point four where in particular we're
talking about planning training
I think you've noticed that you'll see
that training will be delivered by
ethics conservation now there'd a timely
urban design team there daytime length
one and support it by rockler offices I
can't say an issue arising in the next
session of the three major training for
there not to be Wellington to be a
morning session I don't think me any
discretion I think any one of them can
be quite easily
what proposal is that it would be for
officers to decide which worth more
money
and developers right one which one yeah
not explaining into the end of the day a
trainer cannot do it in the morning or
whatever reasons practical reasons they
can't the Russian I don't think we
should dismantling or propose what is
what all sessions not just for non
mandatory sessions yes you can put your
like we're doing my street planning we
actually do MNC licensing in the morning
because we do it feels a little when
they start ten o'clock although it's
people that we can cut we have to go for
appeals we have to come up early so if
we do training it's always in the
afternoon but you could do one of those
sessions in the morning what we're doing
appeals we have to be here anyone supply
might why understandable proposal is
this it is this is to apply for
potentially to apply to all I'll make
sense and then is go get gas I goes
ahead with my charm to cast it as I it
was just something like The Witcher
pictures occurred that we've got the hot
issa decide it has go whether it's the
morning or the afternoon
obviously that's that's going to be in
response to the counselors voicing or so
that they'll obtained in the morning all
the other so it's how many that we would
take isn't it really I mean he felt like
just to it's only 10:30 in the morning
when you've got it say the same thing in
the afternoon or something like that so
when you say what officers discretion
it's it's it's to how many they've got
responses from from the OP from comic
counselors and I think it's a poor guy
anything you know barn up in here I
think what I was saying earlier
never going to you're never going to
it's not be the world Pamela funky I
headed up not meritless oh can I take
those clothes off all those in favor of
the proposal
let's get chairman I just asked a
question for you move on to the exciting
and looking one wise this community I've
just just finished this but that one is
systematize and three will be fit we
will now from time to time offer the
daytime session at in the morning or in
the afternoon Petraglia chairman that
that daddy's for trial period can i
justice confirmations itself yes
is that what the trial period so when to
get a review e after one year would you
say jump that that would probably
boiling now as where menu is hard to be
both useful so we have another vertical
exactly what we're going I thought that
was that although you must rated your
mother adding things to it um people on
our council said there did say free
trial period listed there meter then
give you say from time to time
I didn't hearings like that
did you say this is another way of
staying at the officers discretion not
but it's not the same when it is because
the officers will exercise their
discretion from now on no it's not it's
not okay I probably draw her though and
as I'm sorry I will vote on why here is
put not afterwards
- everything that also the officer
kerrie quite wrongly
I think the proposition has been
proposed seconded and carried my
understanding is that we now move on to
the next item and that's the end of it
thanks thank you for and a crafter you
are correct it can't come back for this
committed for for a period of time six
six months then if I'm incorrect on that
please click well I would like ability
and I'll put it on to the public record
I did not hear in the proposal from time
to time and I did not vote in favor from
time to play the words the use whispers
at the officers discretionary that's
what I expect to see in the minutes and
so from time to time they were necessary
not allowed me the year from private
time mr. Jeremiah distance that we have
the officer to listen to a tape
recording to exactly what would fade and
minute what was actually said and voted
on rather than debating with our
memories because you have a proposition
you had a seconder you had a vote and
that was carried it can't be long time I
Gordon's clear is it members we're not
clear I'm not sure one but what is their
position
Jeremy we have sores on we're a decision
that focuses discretion some training
sessions including the managing planning
they be introduced a morning and an
evening option that's where I thought
the committee's happened I suppose I
just wondered if that was but I mean
that's that's where the committee's out
and we can introduce that so you had to
the rest you backslide hurt get them
looking at their work because this this
committee can review it after a certain
tears in any event uncomfortable so look
at it it's sort of a compliment to fine
so are we happy on that we're having on
that pivotal okay I did have a question
was outside of the slightly outsiders
with tiny sessions or allocations when
they people to particularly Aiden in
there's been cut occasions where hasn't
been enough attendees and that training
session has been cancelled if that was
to happen in the case of a management
assessment that socials are complaining
or would that be risk to the gates that
member because they did entertain to us
because it's not the members for it
something on pants on interpreter but
I've got a support castle better if if a
mentoring session is count it is
cancelled then we can't count against
anyone battery sessions must go ahead if
they're going to extend one of us who's
there is mentioned that's my business
so daddy that's why I fully agree with
you pass the specter of assembly or the
reason yeah yeah I'm just for the arts
to earn item six on six point eight
empower priority when I can you advise
and who where the two members of the
court said and what was the cost and
also pleaded file and the valuable
courses to the council as a whole so
what my graphs 92.9 compose the point is
important the two members were
counseling sport and you are me and a
lot of the quarters were free of charge
thing with them one course a leadership
essential course which involved in
overnight stain that that would think up
about four hundred pounds for councillor
Ward and apart from that there was a
goblin or a little cost which is train
fare
mr. might ask a question on that this is
here there were two members took have
called some of which right now it's not
very clear in future could we have the
costing laws that and the number of
members because I think 1200 elders
quite substantial in overnight stand you
know I say everyone like nothing I've
ever spent that is in London and I'm
saying yes this is my sister she yeah I
wonder is counsel slicing these names
clearly interest rate if they do lighten
recommendation number four there's a
safe darling level one not be learning
or you'll see officers and members
counselor to still knows
I guess won't ask the question is a
label is there any reason why this
training module can't be made available
to members on a DVD or CD or stick or
whatever because you know I find myself
I'm not an iPad using member and there
are others and I don't really want to be
trouble to come into the council offices
and you wouldn't want to pay expenses to
me to do so so if you could supply me
with the CD a DVD I can run that without
any risk to anyone on my own load from
my own PC laptop whatever so I don't
quite understand
show me we can tell that away dirt you
know fun find out you know we should be
able to deliver the ages of colleagues
the late and just how to help on that
I'm not a hundred percent certain on
correcting what I'm about so but I
believe it to be correct is when the IT
system migrates printin and forty three
six family all right
and that will be members will be able to
do that on their own equipment
not just on offense so that would
relieve making your concern that is
right it starts immediately industry
sides nobody came so that's why writing
thank you interesting let me sort of
email will repeat it is a PDF of you can
insert a little bit what you are you
just click on it and like sort of total
even what something what was like that
one is not yeah we can look into gimmick
not only that the easiest way to do is
then you can just click on it and places
it in your own email done I'll get kappa
things I'm doing a couple things that
we've taken about the technology in 2012
our vision should be amusing to see
what's coming this I don't think that if
you emailed it on my experiences test
partition copy though you have to go in
into a system and its architects they
promised ratings and you answer like
multiple choice questions I think you
can't just do it on an email it can the
work people sending through the video
will illegal for a jetsetter yes after
the sake picked up on that point
certainly in my particularly industry
all of the e-learning is done on a
web-based program he's done in sexual
section it is done for the exam and it
has to be done although it's
if you like is done offline but once
you've done the when gone through the
learning you have to sit the exam and
then that is done online and then make
it instilled it so you can't do it from
a DVD you can't do it from an email you
have to go into the system now I will
say normally there please in learning
systems I like that is certainly what
I've come across and that's really where
my space as well is that my speed
learning is through webpage which you
don't which you can use on iPad or PC
you deliver as long as you send a link
to the webpage you can add me until pop
out on the learning can alter my parish
both of you and you're anticipating that
the module would be made available
are you aware at this stage as to
whether there would be a cost to the
parish and Town Council for using that
see little distance I don't imagine them
and yes absolutely so that's how I do my
training and at work I go on to the PC I
have to read you all through and then I
have 22 minutes or whether to answer the
questions so that so I don't we don't
actually have anyone coming giving us
training we do it subtly saying that
I'm not sure because enough information
for you to say those of this I might
patent chairman I mean if you think the
only thing I'd say is that as indicated
in the report it's felt useful for
members to undertake some training on me
on the subject and there has been a key
learning module developed that that it
would it would be appropriate for you
know in terms of that's already being
developed members to interact with
however this isn't isn't suggesting
eLearning in the way that a lot of
members will be used to at this at this
stage if we were to suggest elearning
easily into the training programs i
think we want to come back to the
committee on on some proposals around
there because as it's being suggested
that does involve doing an actual test
where there's a sort of pass and fail
and you know it's this is about just
giving members the opportunity to have a
bit more information on on safeguarding
and and I'd rather officers went away
and communicated with the members that
perhaps may have some difficulty because
they weren't you know that we were not
set up for this per se and then
contacted those those members like my
cancer John Mason yourself then you know
that that something like that I think
subject to that if the committee's
enough
happy it's it's it's more about making
you know depth at that available where
we can now there's no it's no more
maximum I'm happy with an adoption that
takes himself out all the issues that
members have around it here I just take
you in order to cancel everything well
reading this here case is a cost of
putting on the iPad commandment I take
it's on PC at council offices and the
council staff use it is their cost to
put it on the iPad now no so if it goes
on the iPad maybe it might be
interesting to for the members of the
committee to have it first to actually
interact with it and then because I'm
even here the in suggest it goes out to
the rest of the campus to the councilors
if we feel it's a good program and it's
going to be beneficial
well that's what I'm reading here it's a
part so five so long it was those we
going doing that it is anybody that
could be opportunities for us to
actually decide if it's going to be
useful so it's not going to play out
things and make things difficult if it's
going to be straightforward and useful
we can recommend instead go to yeah send
out all the other counselors as illegal
values value held to the end of four
members on the committee is it right in
there to do it for works
I think I want to come as well yeah I'm
just going to mention deflectors I
figure I'll meter just to put it out to
get I'm failing for it and then see how
you've got but still have it as part and
parcel of coming to cancel you know you
can have it both ways isn't it if it
slowly migrating also to place a or onto
the iPad then that's an offense not a
bad thing yes they do
I don't dislike the suggestion my own
concern is it does help League around
delay of the robbery I'd do we need to
come back to another committee meeting
to agreed or can we do it how can we
deal with that so if you could do it I
don't think we should be delaying it
returns fine now we're not quite but
we're going to do the training and offer
it to members in them hope I got it
sooner rather than later
I mean Sharon are all I could draw
members attention to its paragraph 417
that's the light you've had for the most
action requirements because hazard you
to care
Sissoko actual now to risk the Essex a
blogging tool metal board recommend this
level of basic training as a minimum for
counselors there is a requirement at
evidences left the awareness when the
council care exactly safeguarding audits
covering the consulate self assess is
working towards confined with the
requirement so I mean that's the driver
it is for members I suppose you could
have a committee this is a suggestion
that you know the committee sort of
shrining it and if it seems like it's
working in consultation with the
Chairman continue to roll it out to get
to any issues if it's you know something
like that maybe so the question for
adversity or it's a time trying on
getting out to the IPX there's no
mention of time flying on there so
there's a couple months anyway you'll be
next meeting I think it's all being sent
out it's all be Celtics ready 30 minutes
ago so maybe does that say yeah check
and I'd be totally happy that it went
out to all members because being honest
and they're going to trial it doesn't
give us feedback and I think the wider
the audience the better the feedback and
so why just can connect it down to just
for vibrancy to I think that at the end
of it you can do a obvious pointing to
that article or just given three month
or something like that just put your
name to the end I don't see any that's
any other way that you need to it's not
mandatory so you know people you can say
I'm responding to your request or
something on them and I see behind up
there the government and military and
when we started off with a subject on
the trail
said that we have enough information and
I think that is fundamental we have it
on that
to the suggestion from other counselors
though it's trial by members of this
committee I think it's a very positive
one a very good one and I'm sure that
notice of committee could do that if the
timing is a little issue there is no
reason why we have to wait three months
for them standards rating I know that
Catherine we only have four meetings
exact a year but there's no obligation
on us to not have anything and if there
are tiny legal or the essence and you
will feedback from members of the
committee I think it should be dealt
with by this committee that's what this
query is for is to set training and to
enter Liberty at the moment I don't
think we're getting it involved in
trainings we should and our welcome
suggestion counselor esketh I thought it
was an excellent one so I'd like to see
what other members think you leave
educated until you have you once I mean
I think the suggestion moo-cows resume
is very good my fully supported if it's
a proposal I'll second it the only
caveat I'd add to it is to say and if
any other members with with iPads want
to volunteer to undertake the learning
package in this case in there very well
and also to give feedback to to the
Standards Commission I would just go on
to say I think it's very very important
and mr. Bostock actually alluded to this
this is a big change for for us not for
us individually perhaps there's a big
change for the council and I think
there's all sorts of issues that we
have to consider around it so I can
welcome the opportunity for certainly
members of this committee with iPads to
definitely pilot and feedback and any
other members who wish to volunteer
we'd also welcome that that would
actually be incorporated within the
proposal that we have here because in 70
days the office current salient on
mandatory so on that basis would like
correctly understand that you would be
you're not wanting to amenities I would
I'd like to amend it I was like amended
as council roughly put and if he made a
proposal which I think he had that I
executive it because we need to end add
to its the imperatives for an agreement
with a pilot unless there be no
misunderstanding perhaps causal there to
you states quite clearly can actually
spur focus was to the training is if the
Train is erected on the iPad it be
piloted outs as the members of the
committee to make sure it is suitable
and understandable when too easily puts
all other members of the council on
without agreement at a later committee
meeting or as well as an envoy ongoing
role in communication with the chairman
to require hats I'd like to go to rest
of the council Toria a couple jokes
so that's what I previous understood so
yeah and the caveat has actually mean
volunteers who want to be part of the
pilots game
it was the most volunteer members of
this commission the relatives and
volunteers of the forecast if they won't
be parked by that's game as councillor
just nice important whether they make an
idiot Creek even within this compact and
as you learn me well I'll give you more
straightforward or you don't think I
think it's a village i am inviting this
week because module yes you are okay so
I I'm things all talk about how the
members I could accept the proposal
either way either for just the this
committee who have iPads but if we
wanted to be more more liberal if you
like then I'd be equally happy if it was
extended to any other member when I very
wish to get involved in the trial which
brings us back to the original
recommendation intended to be offered to
them not imposed upon that the obviously
state I think chairman
my own view is details important because
I don't want to be back here that I
probably won't be but you know them in a
few months time you know wondering what
the terms were you know Jim can I raise
a point of order here please for my
family we we're talking about members
for this committee and I think we're
only referring to the council members of
this committee we must not forget that
we do have some very table perishable
members represented here saving as we do
have independent measures and should
they not also be included if they as
parking this committee if we're talking
about the members of this committee they
are because of this
that's mrs. wisdom I saw you don't have
to this can be given to us
I just think it's kind of everything I
think it's ready
second all right Milan not tomorrow
right thing is the problem I'll have a
word with the HR department who put it
together and let witnesses absolutely
sure
how's that once why'd you send this out
to members whether you said yes the 21st
all innocent elements you can send it
out how do you know they're actually
going to look at it what trap we got on
the consummating of training sessions
familiar resigned in so we've done
screaming well sandbag response put the
response at the bottom that you've
rating it in my recommendation that
guide your origin - mr. Blevins thank
you and since I chose a committee you're
getting rod book down in lots of detail
or something each week seems quite
simple presuming the binding if I could
have just asked the question
has this been tested by offices and used
by officers yes
so what can it be rolled out to members
why just why don't um why do we need to
take their game to my point that's what
I don't want I think that yes this is
why I would say that we're really
looking at recommendation for and I
don't agree with you are you strong like
what seems to be in fact effective able
to have it sure if I may as has erected
as we've doggies can I approach that we
exactly it organized with Nami think of
anything that might be proposed could I
just have a comment in relation to the
proposal I don't know about that you you
still must remember that some not
everyone on this committee as is able to
them as facility to do this on a my
paper here it needs to be made sure it
can be - orbiter it can be your members
are sailing
if the opportunities that magistrate but
you'll make you're excluding members if
you can t be offered on an iPad I've
gotten all members round the same even
have an eidetic to use that German
officers less field offices with the A's
with with any members that I've got a
slightly different different scenario I
just just to work with them and find
alternatives applied alternatives and it
no it's not mandatory it's just
something that it's felt my views of the
members to engage with and the other be
waste waste saw it it's a bit of it'll
look at that you know will take account
of that because there is an awareness
that it's there's been a training course
developed officers and others have been
involved with on on on safeguarding but
that them's have got different in
circumstances you have to be taken thing
the campus like we have the proposal and
the expense 70 that is to say
recommendation recommendation number
four as status or legend table
item number five communication be sent
from basically villages
asking that they emphasize to their
members that have benefited max number
ten so I emphasize to their members the
benefit of maximum attendance at highly
recommended member training courses I've
got one real conservative highly
recommended member training courses I
Home Office's but my concern is that
there is no member input in the training
session whether they should be
recommended highly recommended itself
this is a committee that it's meant to
oversee training and we don't really
know other than a few headlines what's
going to be offered to members and I
think we should the members should be
deciding what we need training on not
legal is racial you wouldn't go to a
school you'd expect the teachers to
believe that not translators so I think
that probably the Sonia Communications
Group know you have to but do have an
issue with the fact that members are not
involved to a greater degree on
determining the content and the subjects
that we have training for living there
so if I make diaper propose that we
accept the item it is just Kodama be
here second there
hissing thank you much all those in
favor of the recommendation and stasis
cute and again
it's agreed item six
wherever 20 that's completed to the next
meeting of the Standards Committee on
possible boxing for December suggestions
from Parish Town Council's sheriff
contain the only light has done all that
massive desert thank you I spent quite
some consider time visited all
comparisons and quite cost of our
districts and found this to karora I
think the one I attended the longest
enhance the old one all but they all had
a very strong input because a strain and
we had quite a lot of discussion the
biggest single thing that came out of
the training is how we deliver it one of
the suggestions that came out from a lot
of the policies throughout the district
was that could the training being for
particular for planning now that's their
biggest single sensor delivers logic and
by that I mean within the area so the
parish counselors can get to the
training a lot easier the general
thoughts that I had on that was that you
could put several parishes together for
example that I am using example emotions
lipstick right on it if you took for
example founders quavering Barling and
maybe Sutton I did a training session
for those particular counselors I'd say
somewhere central right great wait
possibly at this end of the district
with the tail council perhaps for all
enjoyment LP results perhaps
whole bridge with Hockley I think
there's several combinations that you
could use depending on the plankton when
I asked the parishes and with regards to
the costs on that obviously the more
parishes that I'll get together
the event cost spreads for the from the
training whether it be one of our
officers or whether it be an independent
one that we bring in or the kind that
seems to fit the bill quite nicely and
they were quite keen on that as I
suggest throughout the whole district
the single biggest one that they are
concerned about is planning not whereas
members we come to the management
training here with it's slightly
different for us because of things that
we are looking at or what have you
whereas a parish council is only making
a recommendation or being consulted on
the issue they feel that some of the
training wasn't relevant to them in
terms of the plan so the planning frame
needed to be slightly better tailored
towards the parishes so I think the
plain officer's report you know better
than I'm talking about them the nice
with it so that was a single biggest
thing that came out throughout the whole
discussions that I had with regards to
other training and I think problem that
I founded that there was a certain
amount of apathy around on the training
from the parishes particularly around
health and well-being and things like
that I think there was some some apathy
about that but I think if it was if it
was totally right and done in a similar
sort of fashion I think there would be a
better responsible you know right that
was the general feeling that I had
throughout the whole district district
identify parish representing he
receiving would like to read to them
into that and or anything like this
because I do some work fair at the
meetings when I was there so perhaps
like our 12th and see if I have any
philippa points
this is comfortable on two can do oh yes
the general feeling through Paris at
nationals well our amalgamating
sometimes perishes on a while Olympian
session would be a good way together but
I think the parishes were looking at the
in Sao Paulo and
costings that it would be I loved some
payment of whatever and that what that
would be shared between if you have four
parishes going for instance so figuring
with my head if the district said all
that will cost you a hundred pounds four
parishes will split 100 pounds but I
notice that total bits on here it is
still one representative freeze and a
charge of 40 pounds for every one
thereafter
so you're only gonna get if you have
four parishes you only get four people
turn up
I thought plan was and the whole idea
was that look by doing my amalgamation
as a one of course that you got more
parish councils to go so let's say
everybody or having for bid committee
could go and it would cut down the cost
to parishes because it would be being
split between the numbers of parishes
attending if you're not going to do that
and if you say it's still gonna be just
one free person and everybody else's 40
pounds you might just as well maintain
the status quo because that's not going
to work that I would prove this chair at
the end that was the gem pretentious
comment and before it passed on to
members
this is where the rosary : I would come
into a grave I mean obviously my theme
was the costume you are excited and
particularly on a small parish bring
prohibitive you have they've got to pay
available for five people when it's a
lot of value to a small parish and spike
it fair yeah we do get together and it
is shared between the parish the cost
worked our help people you know one
person going free and you're always
paying for two pound as your medicine I
agree with counsel counsel on and hands
respect I don't think I don't think the
proposal one three and forty pounds for
each one actually going to work at all I
don't you live indeed that's why we
commissioned this piece of work but as a
set want to go except X go around them
so the way I see it is there's going to
be a cost to book paragraph five point
nine physics is going to be a cost to to
the district in doing this i've
personally got no problem we on each
occasion there's a piece of training
that the district council works out what
the cost is and simply put that out as
the opportunity for paratus to subscribe
to and whoever a number of parishes have
agreed to commit to come but that cost
is divided by them when you know the
District Council's not doing any loss
and the parishes are paying the cost
rate czz of that okay to check to make
sure my only thought on that is a good
idea what its long parish had seven
people among parish has one person or
two people other parishes determine say
well I'm not totally
prepare where two people you know six
people
Neal painter in concrete system the
question we have advocated only two four
made some people couple of pointed and
yes I would agree to effect that but it
made 2.48 split it between for the
palace was there but one of the biggest
things was that you know if council
Mason suggestion they will see how many
want to obtain but the whole point was
having it in the right location so they
can get to is easy to propose parish
councilors you know great way to prepare
council doesn't watch for Trevon down to
rate it makes visible so that's why I'm
suggesting it needs to be in allocate
for loading relative to then social
example fairness the bad counsellors of
fairness for them to get anywhere this
into the districts that it was a night
metal charlie it was a plate way cream
they're more likely to attend Richard
Trumka Rogers who can notice their
budget isn't just just for clarification
because I'm getting a sense that was
talked about parish tailored training
and I'm wondering where than that's for
instance that there is planning training
for the perishing Town Council's was
about their type of planning and it's
it's about that going out to the
parishes which is distinct from but
doesn't take which is distinct from the
District Council's training program that
currently charges 40 pounds for one
attendees and I may be wrong with the
system that the district council
programs another way of that parishes
could could be given a cost if it was to
go out to them but this there's the sort
of training that is provided for
parishes where there is ethics
planning that the offices perhaps hole
here I'm getting this wouldn't be right
that that type of training is very much
what what has been being soft yep I
thought if I know sure to press on today
I guess I remember one of the several
comments that some of the parishes that
I had that was that when they protein
particularly planning when they put in
an item under consultation that it's not
necessarily taken that seriously having
read have been on the plan committee for
another years some of the comments were
coming from parishes aren't always clear
to members of the planning committee as
protected what they mean so several
times councils councils and counselors
and also said that their terminology and
how they should be writing into the
districts on those issues was also
something that example could did metal
yes that that being the sort of thing as
the assistant director planning would be
if the training was yeah it would be
weapon the suggestion is that maybe that
that that could be able to do anything
I did it because I think mr. Bostick has
slightly touched on the thing that's
causing and concerned that we're
comparing apples and pears we have at
the moment district health of training
sessions for which were for one free
place and we don't charge for two pound
what I believe is being housed here is
that this is the specific training for
parishes at cost which i think is a big
cookie and I don't think we want a model
at opening up with the forty pound etc
the attendance of district courses I
think is well established by their I
think the composer that has been rain to
around specific courses for parishes in
a location that's suitable for them at
cost is a very positive one a very
healthful one and it certainly would be
around a few parodies and certainly it's
what we've heard as well so I'm sure
that that would be supported the only
point that council Westerman I think
it's a very fair one is that if you've
got parishes of district different sizes
I'm not sure about the attendance
because it tendencies up to the parishes
but if you've got parish of different
sizes perhaps the cost should be
proportionate to the size of the parish
not necessarily the members attending
exhibit that's where the size of the
parish indicates the parish income to a
silver very I think that would be more
equitable than the numbers attending and
then we can get quite difficult because
someone else might turn up and someone
might not turn up but that would be a
suggestion that someone might want to
add to their proposal but thank you this
chain I just a Louisville
or comments from cumulative basically
one counselor mrs. Mason said it's going
to be content cost and location is what
I see my things you found out me so I
think course content or the most
important things it's actually two
tailored to the parishes but who decides
the content would we consult with a
parish is obviously what's comes in
thousands of planning may and see what
they do wrong or they writing stuff in
and does my offense me was always not on
point so it's very much about content
the cost a sort of label you say it's
still going to hopefully still be
cheaper than four we found a person so
you gotta look at that is coming here
with it expenses coming here it's German
even if it helps them just just based on
paragraph five point seven reports is
talking about training session for the
parish and sound councils it's on 8 June
as it happens in the evening run by
District Planning Department the other
part of that paragraph indicates that
parish and town clerk's have been
contacted for us to advise you any
specific planning topics that Kansas
will find useful to be covered which
will form a part the content of the
content of the training I'm sensing it's
possible then the committee may be
thinking that could be thinking that
that that's the sort of thing that that
goes out officers go out to the parishes
on in the way that's being being
discussed allowing you not pro rata for
there for that financial situation that
their size and and getting from them or
they want in that training that's the
direction that yeah Nexus this cheerful
come back I understand as with Mason's
point about charging pro rata I think
there's only with complicated
- to sit down and work out including
their modeling but of course you could
have the situation with the heretic
councils the eastern end of the
districts there's not as many down there
whereas if Roth was to tire the Town
Council because there's so many town
councillors the cost would be
considerably cheaper so should it be /
parish if it's under pound is 25 family
from this war then I'm putting money out
there I don't know it's going to be
quite complicated father so a lot of
price available and I think we must
remember that all being asked to degree
this evening is that it all be submitted
to the next meeting of the Stan's
committing some possible options for
their suggestions from parent aircraft
so I don't want to get into that very
well but I can't cancel Stanley to do
I'd be really like mine yeah I didn't
want to make up one common thing Kevin
with the five seven that three of the
council is one evening and as has
already been noted that there are
several parishes that would be
interested and coming from my distance
and may not be able to make that one
evening and as we have officers that
have to go they go home or they stay
here or whatever they do and then they
everybody comes to this specific venue
there's no reason why we can't actually
just pay their officer
overtime right or every year somebody to
go into those venues which has already
been a looked at or spoken by cancer set
up and the cost for him to go out rather
than the [ __ ] a whole cost and splitting
that cost it is is only one costs and
that's for that officer to go to the
venue and if we arrange for a cost of
Trance
or transplantation mortgage whatever it
is then there's only that one cost and
I'm sure that that won't be anywhere
near as expensive and that could be
supported by lots of district council in
a whole
actually there is usually will be
ill-considered in these times shall I
make a proposal yes well it says whether
to repeal it suppose it is yes to get it
off thank you is that agreed so in item
six please the last item item is unit
[Music]